let's instead go to Bishop from Kentucky
Bishop from Kentucky welcome to the
program uh once you unmute yourself
we'll be able to talk and uh I'm glad to
uh hear about what's on your mind today
oh hello yeah you're on the air
okay
um I just wanted to talk about you've
seen um the recent improvements of um AI
like depicts and stuff right yes
do you think this is ever going to be
like a problem when it comes to like
legal cases like people could um conjure
up evidence that doesn't actually exist
and like without realistic they sound
like and how fast it's improving it
seems to be a bit worrying and I wonder
what your opinion is on that yeah well
so one of the things that we've seen
when it comes to this exact sort of uh
problem is whenever some new technology
becomes widespread which allows either
plagiarism of a new kind or um
fabrication of a new kind
you then create essentially a whole new
like industry of tools and experts
designed to authenticate or to determine
is something plagiarism or is a piece of
evidence real or fake so my expectation
would be that if indeed
using these tools to create fake
evidence in Trials becomes an issue
there will be a new cottage industry of
experts and tools developed
to attempt to authenticate whether
evidence that is presented is really
authentic now is it possible that the AI
technology gets very far ahead of the
authentication technology and it's
impossible to authenticate stuff maybe
but usually whenever this happens
Technologies and experts are developed
and trained to then authenticate what
that new technology is making possible
yeah that's some that sounds fair I was
I've just like seen mostly jokes like um
deep fake jokes like recently like with
like Trump or Biden or Andrew Tate and
they're pretty funny but it's like it
was like slightly worrying how um
realistic they were yeah
um the amount of time that it's like
taken to like Reach This level of
uncompetency when it comes to AI is like
quite astounding I didn't really think
we'd see anything like it at least like
in my early lifetime but it's happening
a lot quicker than I thought and I just
wanted to know your opinion on it it is
happening very quickly you know so far
the Deep fakes of me that have been sent
to me aren't very convincing but
I'm guessing at some point in the next
year or two someone's going to send me a
deep fake of me and it'll probably be
shockingly realistic and it sounds very
scary to be honest
I'm such a concer that will happen yeah
all right Bishop thank you for the call
I appreciate it
thank you so much all right there is
Bishop from Kentucky
plastic it's everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year here's something super
simple you can do to reduce plastic and
help the planet a little bit our sponsor
hold on bags is the company making
plastic free trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags they're just as strong and
high quality as the plastic bags you're
used to hold on bags are 100 plant-based
and home compostable meaning they break
down in just weeks not decades their zip
seal kitchen bags come in sandwich or
gallon size to fit all of your needs
whether it's carrots or crayons at home
I put all of my food waste in a hold on
trash bag throw it in the compost pile
and when I throw a hold on trash bag in
my dumpster I love knowing it's not
filling our landfills and oceans with
plastic single use Plastics harm the
planet at every Stage production
disposal decomposition join the growing
movement away from single-use plastic
these products are really great it's so
easy to make the switch go to hold on
bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below